it is the first day of ufc fan fest at
the las vegas convention center to get
ready for ufc 276 which is happening on
saturday night eight sports now reporter
logan reaver joining us now to fulfill a
promise that he made for us at four
o'clock hi there logan
yes we'll get to the embarrassment in a
second but first this day is about the
fans the first of a two-day event and
people have come from all over for this
event and it's not just the people it's
the diehards there are fighters walking
around here and you would think that it
was the beatles that just entered the
building and that's evident in the
wardrobes outfits everything just like
my man jose perez who you would have
thought was on the main card based on
his getup
do you usually go out with the gloves or
is this a special occasion this thing
just worked today i saved them i got a
charles alberta autograph so excited
about it i wanted a picture maybe i
could get it later but yeah these are
these are for trophies these are for
safety
you're not planning on using them on
anybody are you no i hope not how about
me
i know i think you can take me i can
tell he wants to
so coming up uh well at four o'clock i
should say i uh i made a promise and uh
time to fulfill that promise
unfortunately uh my knees and back are
made of rice krispies but we're going to
give it a shot anyway let's see
can i get some help over here you see it
here let me try sure
all right
i mean it's pretty heavy i don't know if
you can it's it's a tough one yeah
some people are just uh
cut out for it hello from fan fest
i can't at all uh from fan fest logan
reaver live local now
those are some kind of props or
something obviously no no that was
genuine weight and and while
while she held it she also had the
wherewithal to make a phone call phone
call she had to reach out to somebody
girls rule all right